[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce set 8 les
invités une émission dédiée est dédié à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département aujourd'hui jeudi 18 mai
nous parlerons de boxe et de la nuit des
musées
houmadi champion d'europe des super
moyens vient de reprendre son titre
il revient avec nous sur ce combat
marion petit c'est l'un des plus grands
espoirs de la boxe en france il a déjà
remporté deux titres de champion de
france il vise désormais l'europe et
enfin culture avec la 13e nuit des
musées ouverture exceptionnelle gratuite
du musée durant une soirée afin
d'inciter de nouveaux publics à pousser
les portes
bonsoir et pour débuter la boxe avec nos
champions d'elancourt le 5 mai dernier
rappelez vous a dit l'amour ou mady a
réussi à reconquérir son titre de
champion d'europe des poids super-moyens
en terrassant en espagne l'ibérique
mariano hilario nous avons rencontré
après sa victoire ce boxeur de 36 ans il
revient sur ce combat et sur ses futurs
objectifs avec notamment en ligne de
mire une couronne mondiale
entretien michael et me d'euros à mes
côtés l'un des meilleurs boxeurs
français du moment a dit lahm ou mady
qui nous vient tout droit des l'encours
et qui vient de remporter la ceinture de
champion d'europe de boxe alors a dit là
comment vous sentez vous après ce titre
remporté face à hilario dans l'espagne
je les sens plutôt bien et
comptant même fier de moi d'avoir amené
cette ceinture et du coup ce combat
élite et comment à bas le combat était
stratégiquement bien bien conçu j'avais
une tique y aller
qui avec avait eu l'oeil dessus on a pu
travailler sur les défauts d'hilario
comme le qualité de vie lario donc ça
n'a pas été un combat qui a été
placé au hasard on savait comment
fallait le bac c'est maintenant le
combat certes si on n'avait pas fait la
différence à voir sur surtout les routes
je pense pas qu'on nous aurait laissé
gagner le combat surtout pas là bas et
c'était un adversaire que vous
connaissiez déjà que vous avez déjà
battu pour le titre de champion d'europe
également
c'est ça c'est ça j'avais déjà battu
pour le championnat d'europe la première
fois il ya deux ans j'ai pu remporter
8e rouge par arrêt de l'arbitré mais
les conséquences qui ont pu à qui a pu
la voir sont quasiment les mêmes que la
première fois l'arbitré c'est de leur
côté voilà c'était vraiment c'était
vraiment ça là le combat il a été
jusqu'au bout c'est jusqu'au bout et on
n'a pas voulu l'arrêter avant été
jusqu'au bout et c'était plus compliqué
ce combat là qui à deux ans ont
finalement c'est à peu près la même
chose
non pas spécialement plus compliqué pour
moi mentalement c'était
c'est très bien c'est pas et je suis
quand je suis je suis je suis je suis
donc on mange ici maintenant lui
mentalement ils étaient préparés et
c'est surtout préparer mentalement voilà
donc ça a été dur il a tenu donc
physiquement et et il est et il était
plus en forme que moi parce qu'en même
temps il était aidé a pu la dernière
fois qu'on s'est rencontrés c'était il
ya deux ans moi j'ai boxé trois fois en
30 ans et lui a boxé cette fois donc
forcément il a il a pu acquérir de
l'expérience de l'assurance aussi vous
avez 36 ans est ce que vous avez espérer
dans vos rêves les plus fous redevenir
champion d'europe à un moment alors que
tous pensaient si je peux dire cramer
pas spécialement après j'aime bien dire
ça aussi je suis pas un rêveur voilà
rêver c'est quand on dort non on ne sait
pas grand chose donc moi je sais
vraiment plus quelqu'un qui à qui les
objectifs
voilà ils m'ont vu se disent attendre
voilà j'avais eu six mois je suis avec
ma le monde connaît d'ailleurs que je
remercie
qui pour lui était censé devait
justement revenir au niveau
européens pour pouvoir repartir sur un
niveau mondial ça pas louper on l'a fait
donc non j'ai l'objectif était de
revenir déjà dans un premier temps aux
nouveaux repères pour pouvoir aller au
niveau mondial aujourd'hui je me dis bah
le prochain cru à tort que ça soit monde
vous n'avez pas douté un seul instant
sur notre condition physique vous avez
confiance en nous j'ai confiance après
le doute et à partir de là certains
celle ci on commence à douter on avance
plus on tue moi j'ai besoin d'avancer je
suis confiant et voilà c'est c'est
encore un grand plaisir de pratiquer la
boxe
donc c'est pas vraiment qu'il faut que
je commence à douter
je pense être encore en forme et puis on
peut encore faire ce qu'on peut faire
le juge est plus plaisir à monter sur le
ring on arrête là je pourrai commencer à
douter
voilà vous fixé encore combien d'années
dans la boxe en a une vingtaine d'années
peut-être pas je suis présent non je
pense que j'ai encore mon coup à faire
jeu 2-3 ans je pense vous bonifier avec
l'âge peut-être je sais pas après on
prend de l'expérience l'expérience s'est
passé pas négliger et puis on connaît
encore mieux notre corps que peut-être
d'autres et puis c'est juste qu'on peut
aller jusque on veut aller
quels sont les sacrifices aussi qu'il
faut mettre en place pour y arriver la
prochaine étape
forcément championnat du monde prochaine
étape c'est ce qu'on remettra peut-être
le titre en le titre hors pair angers
qu'on leur met une fois en jeu
pour pouvoir le faire le seul français
le faire en france ça serait un mais un
plaisir fou andromède mettre la ceinture
européenne en france et puis ensuite
attaqué directement levée du monde
vous avez déjà des adversaires en tête
ou note encore j'essaie de l'est
la team s'en occuper bon moment dernière
question est ce que vous le gardez cette
ceinture ici à elancourt donc je vais la
garder forcément je regardais cette
ceinture et on la gardera et donc on
quand j'aurai pu fort que ça soit moi
qui décide de ne plus garder cette
ceinture pour accéder à une ceinture
supérieure
merci beaucoup a dit la lpo courage pour
vous j'en conviens bien smithy works et
toujours avec une rencontre annoncée sur
tv fil 78 depuis plusieurs semaines
c'est un des plus grands combats de sa
carrière que marvin petit va disputer ce
jeudi 18 mai le sportif d'elancourt
double champion de france va défier au
cirque d'hiver de paris l'espagnol
gerber santana pour la ceinture de
l'union européenne un combat
initialement prévu en janvier mais à
l'ibérique avait annulé le combat deux
jours avant l'événement on écoute le
boxeur français au micro de notre
journaliste sportif michael et demi
d'euros là je me sentais en pleine forme
je suis bien préparé et j'ai fait une
grosse préparation physique une espagne
donc là je pense que je suis prêt à 100%
vous entraînez depuis combien de temps
là ça fait trois mois j'étais deux mois
attentes
avec beau petit un très très bon
préparateur physique
pourquoi maintenant le jour il arrive ce
jeudi c'est bonjour je dois pas le
laisser passer
comment avez vous analysé votre
adversaire passe-passe holding mais
c'est vrai que après voilà j'ai regardé
quelques vidéos et bon voilà c'est un
bon technicien
après je pense que ça fera pas moi je
suis quelqu'un qui va avancer tout le
temps je vais pas le lâcher
donc je vais
tout ce que j'ai bon qu'est ce qui va
faire la différence selon vous la
différence c'est que j'ai
un grand coeur c'est un grand mental je
vais pas lâcher cette ceinture à la moi
vous avez la réputation d'attirer les
foules
il y aura encore énormément de monde qui
va venir au cirque d'hiver pour vous
voir boxer est ce que vous allez jouer
là dessus
après je vais pas jouer sur les souris
spectateurs mais je les jeux pour moi
c'est
déjà de lui il faut que j'arrête c'est
obligatoire c'est une ceinture qui est
très importante dans ma carrière
donc je vais chercher cette ceinture et
après dans un seul toit de l'europe
qu'est ce que ça représente un titre
européen ça représente beaucoup beaucoup
de travail
la preuve bon couture qu'est ce que ça
représente aussi au niveau du palmarès
c'est peut-être le combat peut-être le
plus important de votre vie de votre
jeune carrière
c'est ouais c'est un des combats le plus
important de ma carrière aussi parce que
c'est bon c'est un très bon boxeur je ne
sous estime pas le bon boxeur jamais
sous-estimer un bouchon il va voir
ivoire ou du moins quand même parce que
je suis prêt là je suis prêt à 100% je
veux pas l'usagé de aucune chance et ça
sera que le début peut-être la carrière
de débats reviennent petit même si vous
avez déjà été double champion de france
est ce que ça sera le début de la
carrière la grande carrière de marvin
petit on sera le début d'un bon gardien
exactement donc là je challenger
européen donc ce titre nous fait
obligatoire pour arriver sur le toit de
mondiale et dustin ses droits marine
petit pourra compter sur le soutien du
public le combat se dispute à guichets
fermés culture avec la nuit des musées
qui revient pour une treizième édition
cette année encore le musée de la ville
de saint quentin en yvelines ouvrira ses
portes
l'occasion pour nous de découvrir la
nuit les nouveaux locaux et l'exposition
en cours consacrés au vintage
le point avec lucie sauvageau du musée
de la ville lucie sauvageau bonjour vous
êtes la responsable action culturelle du
musée de la vie et 50 ans participe
cette fois encore à la nuit des musées
c'est la 13ème édition c'est ça c'est ça
alors que va-t-il se passer ce week-end
alors cette année là minimisé ce sera au
tour de l'exposition vintage regard dans
le rétro en lien avec cette exposition
on a souhaité faire un mouvement autour
du rétro gaming puisque c'est un
phénomène très tendance qui permet de
jouer à des jeux vidéo
de boxe 1970 au milieu des années 1990
donc c'est ça permet de jouer sur des
consoles d'époque à des jeux d'époque
ça c'est la première partie de cette
nuit des musées la deuxième partie sera
autour de 40 ans visé puisque c'est
cette année l'année anniversaire de la
création de l'écomusée de saint quentin
en yvelines en 1977
l'un des musées viennent de lui l'idée
c'est de découvrir aussi peut-être le
musée d'une autre manière
oui l'idée c'est d'avoir un moment
convivial sur un tank d'habitude vous et
fermez donc la nuit en soirée c'est
vraiment un événement qui est fait pour
appréhender mieux et différemment
et puis pour venir en famille ou entre
amis c'est des propositions qui souvent
sont s'adresse à un public assez jeune
etc voilà une autre occasion de venir on
faisait de manière peut-être plus
décontractée que d'habitude mais parler
de vétroz gagner quelques noms de jeu
peut-être ou de console je ne sais pas
qui seront présentes
alors oui des noms de consoles à la
bombe
traditionnel c'est bien amstrad pas
toutes ces consoles acquis qui ont
marqué bien des générations d jeu pacman
super mario bros des jeux bien sûr
qu'ils sont antique et que tu connais
même si on n'y a pas jouer forcément
notamment les plus jeunes générations
sous leur forme en ciel c'est une
association là qui va qui nous a prêté
ce matériel et qui va venir avec ses
consoles et ses jeux une association de
passionnés
cette association s'appelle et nos cinq
points comme ils ont une quantité de
collection rétro des knicks qui font
intervenir et qui est à même matériel
pour la partie espace de jeux donc leur
à deux bornes en libre accès multi
joueurs avec des gens qui seront là pour
expliquer comment ça marche
et puis pour le tournoi il y aura un
tournoi également mon petit joueur et le
tournoi se fera sur saturn bomberman
donc un jeu vidéo des années 1990 2010
et c'est aussi les 40 ans du musée
comment ça va se concrétiser par c'est
dans cette nuit des musées une visite
particulière peut-être mon ce sera une
expo dossier à the sur les 40 ans de
nous et qui nous permet à la fois de
retracer une chronologie de ses 40 ans
en quelques dates phares et puis de
ressortir des documents d'archivés mais
aussi des corrections qui ont marqué de
période d'acquisition qui sont qui sont
symptomatiques de différentes
orientations du musée de ses recherches
différentes au long de ses quarante ans
c'est la fin de ce cette fuite les
invités vous pouvez retrouver toutes nos
séquences en replay sur l'application
terrifié 78 ou sur internet tv fil 78
points comme en attendant bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]